[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
empezamos en el norte de américa en eeuu
porque la opinión de la corte suprema de
justicia sobre la interrupción legal del
embarazo género manifestaciones desde la
costa este a la oeste el derecho al
aborto podría ser interrumpido cuando el
máximo tribunal del país emita el fallo
en julio y bajamos hasta suramérica a
argentina donde un grupo de mujeres
enfermeras que prestaron sus servicios
durante la guerra de las malvinas piensa
reconocidas como ex combatientes nuestro
corresponsal habló con una de ellas y
hablamos de la guerra en ucrania que
aunque no está en nuestro continente lo
impacta revisamos como la industria
agrícola en brasil está marcando la
campaña para las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre debido a la
escasez de fertilizantes cuyos
principales componentes provienen de
rusia
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal un texto de la corte
suprema de justicia- fechado en febrero
y filtrado esta semana al portal digital
político en un hecho sin precedentes
dejó ver la intención de los magistrados
de revocar el fallo del caso conocido
como roe versus wade de
1973 el cual le otorgó a nivel federal
el derecho a las mujeres a interrumpir
voluntariamente el embarazo
el borrador de 98 páginas de la eventual
decisión que no tiene efecto inmediato
dice que la sentencia estaba equivocada
pues la constitución no hace referencia
al aborto y cobra relevancia ahora
porque la corte suprema de justicia está
revisando una ley de misisipí que
prohíbe interrumpir el embarazo desde la
semana 15 de gestación se espera que los
magistrados anuncien una decisión en
julio
el presidente joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
manifestaron su oposición a la eventual
reversión del derecho en un hecho que ya
marca la campaña de cara a las
elecciones de medio término que se
celebrarán en noviembre y en las que se
renovará un tercio de la cámara de
representantes y la totalidad del senado
mientras los y las estadounidenses se
vuelcan a las calles tanto en favor como
en contra de la anulación de este
derecho y el senado que es de mayoría
demócrata ya anunció un proyecto para
protegerlo
y
esos líderes republicanos que están
tratando de usar la ley como un arma
contra las mujeres bueno les respondemos
como se atreven como se atreven a
decirle a una mujer lo que puede y no
puede hacer con su propio cuerpo
como se atreve
como se atreven a tratar de detenerlas
de tomar decisiones sobre su propio
futuro
como se atreven a tratar de negarle a
las mujeres sus propios derechos y
libertades entre sí
y es que el texto con la decisión está
firmado por cuatro magistrados hombres y
afecta al 58 por ciento de las mujeres
de eeuu que están en edad de concebir
miren se trata de los conservadores
samuel alito y clarence thomas wright
cavani newgard switch y amy cón y
barrett los tres últimos fueron
nombrados por el ex presidente
republicano donald trump
recordemos ahora el caso roe versus wade
en 1969 a los 21 años una mujer llamada
norma mccorvey quedó embarazada por
tercera vez protegió a su identidad con
el seudónimo jane y solicitó
autorización para interrumpir su tercer
embarazo en el estado de texas el fiscal
del condado de dallas henry white
rechazó la petición argumentando que
sólo se podía interrumpir un embarazo si
la vida de la madre estaba en peligro la
defensa de mccarthy presentó una demanda
federal argumentando que las leyes
estatales de texas que prohibían el
aborto eran inconstitucionales mientras
se producía el fallo norma tuvo una hija
y la dio opciones
casi la mitad de los 50 estados de eeuu
prohibirían inmediatamente la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo si
es revocado el fallo ya que tienen leyes
estatales aprobadas que fueron
bloqueadas por el fallo federal estos
son los estados que ven en rojo en sus
pantallas que son tradicionalmente
conservadores entre ellos están idaho
yuta arizona las dakotas iowa misurí
oklahoma texas arizona luciana wisconsin
michigan ohio kentucky tennessee
misisipí alabama virginia occidental
georgia y carolina del sur los estados
en amarillo probablemente lo harían es
decir podrían tomar algunas medidas
restrictivas pero variaría el número de
semanas por ejemplo en el caso de
florida donde el gobernador ruandés
santis promulgó recientemente una ley
que lo prohíbe desde la semana 15 otros
estados en esta categoría son montaña
wyoming nebraska e indiana
este es uno de los temas más polémicos
en eeuu junto al porte de armas sin
embargo según una encuesta publicada por
el mismo portal político que filtró el
documento el 50 por ciento de los
estadounidenses consultados cree que el
fallo no debería revertirse el 28 por
ciento cree que sí y el 22 por ciento no
tiene una opinión al respecto según el
censo de 2020 la población femenina en
eeuu representa el 50 52 por ciento del
total ligeramente superior a la
masculina
vamos ahora el sur del continente a
argentina porque hace 40 años en la
segunda semana de mayo de 1982 mónica
rodríguez viajó a comodoro rivadavia una
ciudad de la patagonia sobre el océano
atlántico fue a prestar sus servicios de
enfermera de la fuerza aérea en el marco
de la guerra de las malvinas que había
comenzado un mes antes cuando fuerzas
argentinas desembarcaron en las islas y
reino unido- respondió lanzando una
contraofensiva estuvo allí hasta la
rendición de argentina el 14 de junio de
1982 atendiendo a todos los heridos en
combate muchos años después de la guerra
un grupo de 14 enfermeras que prestaron
servicios durante el conflicto
comenzaron a pedir ser reconocidas como
ex combatientes la comodoro mónica
rodríguez es una de ellas y habló con
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio cosos
hola mónica rodríguez s enfermera de la
fuerza aérea argentina
esta es la medalla otorgada por el
congreso a todos los veteranos de
malvinas en mayo de 1982 fue desplegada
a un puerto de la patagonia junto con
otras enfermeras durante la guerra
atendió a los heridos que llegaban de
las islas y en la parte que estaba yo
venían heridos como más graves no venían
heridos con esquirlas
quemaduras amputaciones
por su tarea mónica rodríguez junto con
otras tres enfermeras que atendieron a
los heridos pide ser reconocida no solo
como veterana sino también como ex
combatiente el ex combatiente es como
que participó más de esa guerra tiene un
reconocimiento no solamente social sino
económico y eso creo que marca la
diferencia no en el acto conmemorativo
de los 40 años del inicio del conflicto
el presidente alberto fernández se
refirió explícitamente a los hombres y
mujeres que participaron de la guerra
cuando hace pocos días decíamos con
fuerza y decisión nunca más
también lo extendemos a nuestros héroes
y heroínas de marina para que nunca más
vuelvan a caer en el olvido y el
silencio de parte de ningún gobierno sin
embargo ante la consulta de este medio
sobre el reclamo de rodríguez y sus
compañeros la única respuesta que dio el
gobierno fue el envío de esta resolución
de 2012 que daba otro tipo de
reconocimiento a otras mujeres algo
independiente del caso de rodríguez y
mientras tanto porque cree mónica
rodríguez que no se le ha otorgado el
reconocimiento de excombatientes yo creo
que se unió al todo yo creo que si un
estado se unió el que seamos mujeres se
unió al que seamos enfermeras porque eso
también sirve y porque somos
continentales y aunque hay ex
combatientes que creen que quienes no
estuvieron en las islas no deben tener
ese reconocimiento mónica rodríguez y
sus compañeras están convencidas de que
si ya dos de ellas obtuvieron sentencias
favorables en la justicia mónica
rodríguez va a buscar la suya cuando se
retire de la fuerza aérea
y seguimos en américa del sur en brasil
un país que depende en gran medida de la
industria agrícola la invasión rusa a
ucrania ha tenido allí varias
consecuencias inesperadas como el temor
a la escasez de los principales
componentes de los fertilizantes que
provienen de rusia en su mayoría
nuestros corresponsales en brasil fueron
al agrishow el epicentro del lobby
agrícola donde había un invitado de
honor en plena precampaña de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
en el corazón del estado de sao paulo
más de 520.000 metros cuadrados se
utilizan para desarrollar tecnología
agrícola y sus productos
y el invitado de honor es esperado con
ansias para inaugurar una de las mayores
ferias del mundo
en medio de la pre campaña electoral el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro ha venido a
consolidar el apoyo de su base con uno
de los asuntos más polémicos de brasil
sobre la mesa los depósitos de
fertilizantes desde que empezó la
invasión rusa ucrania
a pesar de los comentarios de algunas
personas de que mi visita con putin no
era oportuna
hemos recibido la noticia de que casi 30
barcos llenos de fertilizantes están en
camino desde rusia
casi el 25% del potasio y el fosfato
presentes en los fertilizantes proceden
de rusia lo que causa preocupación entre
los productores como riccardo kurion e
la fosforito
brasil depende en gran medida de la
agricultura así que no ha sancionado a
los países en guerra precisamente para
asegurar que se siguen recibiendo barcos
con fertilizantes
pero la situación sigue siendo
preocupante para nosotros y para los
campesinos que usan nuestro producto y
una de las soluciones según bolsonaro es
utilizar el suelo de las reservas
indígenas que supuestamente son ricas en
potasio
nuestro presidente encontró la
alternativa muy inteligente quiere que
brasil sea independiente en términos de
materias primas por supuesto no de la
noche a la mañana pero tenemos que hacer
un buen comienzo
en el parlamento en brasilia la
oposición está iracunda
el gobierno debe cerrar las fábricas de
fertilizantes brasil ha decidido de
manera consciente ser dependiente de las
importaciones pero la verdadera solución
está en otro lugar debemos hacer las
cosas diferente tenemos que cambiar la
forma en la que hacemos las cosas en
brasil tenemos que usar fertilizantes
menos contaminantes
gobiernos
y de acuerdo con un reciente informe
académico las tierras indígenas no son
tan ricas en potasio como el gobierno
asegura en un profundamente polarizado
brasil incluso el fertilizante es un
motivo de conflicto
y me despido con las imágenes de la
primera gira internacional del
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador que decidió visitar las naciones
del triángulo norte de centroamérica con
el fin de coordinar con sus homólogos
una respuesta conjunta para atender los
problemas que originan la migración
hacia el norte
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
joan y agudelo pueden ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas para
más información de nuestro continente
siguen viendo france24
[Música]